hello everyone and welcome to another
really wild game uh from the final round
of the second day so basically round six
of the champions showdown chess nine
sixteen yanipan versus shakhtar mahmoud
of so young was having a spectacular
tournament had four wins in a row then
he faced alireza and alireza defeated
him with the white pieces but he is
still tied for first and now uh he faces
uh shakhri mahmoud he has the wide
pieces and it's uh well it's quite a
quite a crushing game uh so let's check
it out nepo has the white pieces and he
opens with f4 now he opens up his dark
square bishop sorry about that
uh we have d5 uh by uh shakti are g3 and
f6 now we have pawn to d4
now stopping stopping e5 and knight to
d6 we have knights to d3 and knight to
g6 now bishop to h3 by nipple and now
pawn to e6 we have knight h to f2 and
now pawn to b6 uh bishop to g2 uh fiance
in the bishop and now pawn to e5 emma
media strikes in the center we have d
captures on e5 f captures on e5 and now
uh while you could uh start capturing an
e5 nipple decides to advance the pawn to
e4 he doesn't want to be stuck with a
backward spawn d captures we have knight
captures an e4 and now all sorts of
nasty discoveries are being threatened
for example knight captures would open
up an attack towards the queen so it
makes sense to block this bishop to d5
now challenges the bishop here and here
you uh black is definitely at least
slightly better and you should consider
castling um
maybe
wouldn't be wouldn't be a terrible idea
but that's the problem here nipple
played knight captures on d6 and uh now
uh mamidarov has a move that is well
sort of puts him in a completely winning
position so feel free to pause the video
and try to find this winning idea for
mommy yarf while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting this brilliancy and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is bishop to f3 check a weird move
indeed but it puts white in a really
really terrible position uh point is if
the bishop is captured for example
bishop captures an f3 oh sorry about
that
if bishop captures an f3 queen captures
on f3 and now king to c1 then bishop
captures on d6 and
there's really nothing for you to do the
king is stuck on c1
even if you try something like a4 to
bring the queen into the game we can
even play knight captures on f4 if g
captures e for now chases away the
knight bishop captures on f4 uh will
will end the game so that's that's the
problem so after this bishop to f3 check
king to d2 by nipple and now bishop
captures on d6 again the idea is the
same e4 uh will be played the knight
captures and f4 becomes a terrible
threat and there's just uh not a good
way to deal with this bishop to h3 by
nipple now pawn to e4 attacking the
knight and now b4 uh it's a good move in
most positions so it could be a good
move in this position it even is the top
move recommended by the engine uh but
still it's it's a hard position to play
now the problem is if you move the
knight and of course you want to do this
if it's possible uh queen d5 check and
if king c1 bishop b4
uh there's nothing uh for you to do here
it's uh the rook is hanging let's say c3
e3 now queen to d to check is coming the
checkmate is coming uh it's just a
terrible position to be in so instead
nipple played b4 uh we have rook to e7 a
very classy move by momodaro he doesn't
just rush with e captures on d3 he
defends the g7 pawn he says i'm not
giving you uh you know a shred of
counter play so knight's the c5 nepo
says all right i will give you the
knight but on my terms i want to give it
up here so we might start start trading
but momidaro just continues with his
plan of knight captures on f4 as that's
the way to victory so g captures uh the
bishop is also hanging there's really no
good move here for white g captures and
now it the only way this game would have
been cooler if mahmoud did not capture
on c5 if he went for bishop to capture
son uh f4 right away but okay he played
b captures in c5 uh we have bishop b
captures on c5 and now bishop captures
and f4 with check now the bishops here
are just monsters uh king to c3 or you
could play bishop to e3 but then you
just get very quickly checkmated queen
d5 check and that's it king to c1 let's
say or somewhere if you don't want to
give up the bishop you can play queen d4
but just queen captures on d4 and the
bishop is spin so bishop to e3 really
does not help you so instead we have
kinked the c3 now comes pawn to e3 and
now rook eat the d1 with check king to
e8 and now rook captures nb8 with check
queen captures and now even rook to d4
trying to
get something yeah if mamirov tries
bishop to e5 which of course i'm sure
nipple was was planning uh then he would
get some counterplay let's say bishop
captures an e3 and after captures
captures yes of course black is still
winning he's up material but the two
bishops the queen the blacking in the
open board might not be so easy and
there are both some maybe three minutes
on the clock so after rook d4 we have c6
again just limiting nipples options and
now king to d3
queen to b5 with check pawn to c4 and
now queen to b4 threatening queen to d2
checkmate so king to c2 now comes pawn
to e2 and there is no good way to deal
with pawn to e1 so here rook captures on
f4 at least he will uh grab a bishop
while while he uh you know resigns the
game but that's pretty much it rook
captures on f4 and mamadar played e1 and
he didn't even bring the queen into the
game he brought a knight into the game
with check uh and it was in this
position on move 25 that yannipon should
resign the game as there is nothing more
to be done here uh so yeah really really
nicely done uh
bringing a queen into the game aurora
rook is also winning but bringing a
knight with check is just way cooler uh
because now white can give up the queen
or you can start running away with the
king but then it's just a force
checkmate with knight d3 check king c2
rookie 2 check now you sacrifice the
knight you just brought into the game
captures and of course queen to d2 will
be checkmate so nepo saw this of course
he resigned and that's pretty much it
and now the standings that some of you
already
uh were able to see even though for a
fraction of a second uh these are the
standings after round six so that
incredible uh mamidyarov uh is uh tied
for alireza uh uh uh on with four and a
half points in first place then with
four yanipanishi who started off with
four wins but then that lost uh against
alireza um i really got to him as you've
seen how how quickly uh he just uh
completely blundered in in the opening
basically against the mamidarov uh then
with three and a half points fabiano
levon and hikaru nakamura with three
points wesley so with two linear
dominguez petersfielder with one and a
half and kasparov still with zero points
after six rounds so we'll see if maybe
uh after the after the final day he will
grab a point or two
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very very nicely done by
mommy jarov and you know it really came
out of nowhere bishop to d5 just uh
spectacularly played and he just tricks
nepal just knight captures on d6 and
then this bishop to f3 check move who
would who would spot this but mamidar
would spot this uh so yeah once again
really hope you guys enjoyed it uh i
would like to thank paul sertanovich
palacio filippo palacio esu papa in
panama matthew garner and luke longbone
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the champions showdown uh
until it finishes uh so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day